LE RUSSIANOPWHAT HE DESCRIBEANDR
HAD.NT TO GET YOURCO
EASTERN AT A
HASTHEIE
DISCUSSED
JUST A FEW OF KY S
WHAT SE
PIECES.
LOOKS  I
RULLOD ON  THEY'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING
EAST.
SO WHERE THESE P
TAKEN IS EAST  THA ARE GOING
DOWN INTD
LUHANS REGIONS
UKRAST.E GOING TO TO TAKE
ST. CLEAR
HE UKRAINIS NEEDVERY CEF AT THI
TH'RE DOING REGA
BUT HAVING SAID , LUMNS ARE ALS
AND WT
INTELLIGENCE ANDTHINK THEY'LL BL
>>HES EXPECTED TO BE
INTENSE FIGHTING IN THE EASTERN
PART ORAET CLOSER TO MAY
VICTORY DAY,MOMENT FOR THEAN
, SOMETHING
N TO CELEBRATE AND TOUT WITHUKIK
U WELL.
>> I JUSUR
ASSESSMENT OF WHATS LIKE FORTHE
BUCHA.
YOU ATO TO FOLKS  AROUND WHEN D
WHAT HAVE ANYONE MIGHT HE ACK AE
LEFBEHIND
SERVICE. SUNDAY RN ERE WAA  SER
GRAVE IN THE CHURCHARD.
THEYSIHUME
BURIAL.IESTGIVENM A PROPER
N HIDING HERE INUC THE RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION, BUNGREGA
ISING, COMING OUT OF
TO GETACSORT OF TS
G NOW D ONES TO BE A VERES